if i were in a beauty pageant what would  my talent be i really don't think if i  was beautiful enough to be in a beauty  pageant i would scoff at the talon  challenge because i don't think that  they even should have to do that  if you're hot enough  it should actually be a lack of talon  challenge for a beauty pageant because  if you're hot enough you should not have  to lift a single finger or do anything  unique because you're that hot unless  the talent contest is like  who can eat an ass better or like blow a  dick or something that's like hack  though i would rather  them to just  be talentless the talentless the more  beautiful i mean if i was pretty enough  i would just go in there and try and win  the judges over in some way like that i  would just be like my talent is i'm  [ __ ] hot